j'accueille armande altaï
nous sommes à dammarie les lys et voici
le château le plus médiatisé de l'année
celui de la star academy parmi les 250
personnes qui travaillent sur les
missions règne aujourd'hui une certaine
tristesse le jeu s'achève demain il va
falloir se séparer très beau
la petite fontaine moussu de petites
marches c'est bon ça difficulté c'est
que je suis attaché mon coeur est grand
mais il ya les élèves de l'année
dernière ceux de cette année est la
difficulté est là quoi c'est comment les
suivre je leur laisse la porte ouverte
j'aime bien quand il me donne des
nouvelles
j'ai pas des nouvelles de tout le monde
et je j'aimerais bien avoir
je pense que c'est la der des ders très
beau tenter par eux ça prend une autre
dimension
bien que j'ai encore beaucoup de
reproches à leur faire
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
armande altaï à paris à la tombée de la
nuit dans le quartier du marais où elle
donne des cours de chant le trio est
situé dans une ancienne bâtisse
regardez ce lieu magic tous ces
bâtiments
17e qui sont très très beau à l'eau mais
je suis pas en retard du tout alors là
c'est dans ma classe de chambre des
anciens il forcé des anciens sans que
c'est devenu des amis s'en prennent à
leurs à leur aise il ya des anciens qui
ont connu dans l'om par exemple que j'ai
été plusieurs années puis les tout
nouveaux comme les lits qui sont encore
au lycée et que j'ai eu encore plus
jeunes et voilà on va faire un cours
entre nous un peu poussé ici les gestes
sont les mêmes qu'à la star academy
inspiration expiration et vocalises
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un d'unique je trouvais
avoir une gentillesse incroyable et
possibilité de nous apprendre incroyable
le cours est terminé mais la soirée
d'armande altaï ne fait que commencer
j'aime paris
je suis urbaine je déteste les vacances
et quand il ya plus personne pour
travailler
peut-être que je suis un peu addict au
travail ce que leurs proches mes proches
or comme elle n'est pas du matin elle
concentre son activité l'après midi et
le soir
j'ai une position confortable et
finalement parce que je reste très
marginal est en effet j'arrive à vivre
de cette musique
j'ai eu très populaire armande continue
de susciter la curiosité weylandt ont
très vite alors est ce qu'après faut que
je m'arrête je suis ce soir elle donne
un concert sur la scène parisienne de
l'alhambra
mais avant les répétitions elle tient à
s'arrêter dans son salon de thé
préférées
l'endroit est calme la star du chant et
protéger des demandes d'autographes
durant quelques instants
une fois dehors je me dis je suis pas je
suis pas tout à fait livre quelquefois
je suis pressé quelquefois j'ai pas
envie qu'on voit pas ce que je suis pas
bien tout ça mais ils sont tellement
gentils que je leur fais un petit
sourire j'essaye de développer un même
pas rapide mais moi je peux pas
convaincre direction la salle de concert
pour ses répétitions il n'y a qu'une
seule date et pour la chanteuse il est
donc essentiel que tout soit parfait
[Musique]
à une époque je faisais tout moi même je
dessinais mes décors et tout donc là je
suis insupportable parce que sait jamais
comment on rêve les choses on les rêves
et puis tout d'un coup ça se passe
autrement mes pieds je suis un peu
nerveuse armande altaï s'écrit en
univers fantasmagorique baroque passé
mon grimoire un livre de magie avec mes
textes mais ruban et ce à une plume de
phoenix attention cette plume ce que si
vous la posséder vous avez tendance à
vous envoler
je pense tu es un peu gamine enfin
détendue elle met la dernière touche au
décor deux choses sont en enlève
carrément ça sont des croches et on les
laisse pendre les rideaux comme ça et
celui là je vais l'accrocher ma manière
puisque accroché là où comme ça c'est
pas bien qu'on ait créé près armande se
prépare et chauffe sa voix sous des
regards admiratifs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais chanter des chansons turques je
vais chanter à bergues olesz mais dans
tout ça je vais chanter des chansons que
j'ai écrites
récemment il ya très longtemps et qui
sont un mélange de tout ça sic et
baroque bareille
voilà je pour cette soirée unique la
chanteuse réserve quelques duos
inattendus restait 300 spectateurs
c'est un personnage légendaire c'est
beaucoup de bonheur et c'est un grand
honneur d'être invité
à chanter avec elle en duo qui la
rendent c'est ça aussi un talent
incroyable devant une enchanteur reste
de raconteuse elle est moche et nous
allons bien mérité
les travaux
salle avec un orage
se déchaînent exprès sépare
la diva reviendra-t-elle un jour
transmettre son art dans le monde de la
télé réalité
et maintenant les lumières se rallument
sur armande altaï
bienvenue dans tout le monde en a parlé
merci merci de me recevoir alors à
remonter tenue le 20 mai 1944 à alep en
syrie sous le nom de armande coumba ka
bart et altaï majinis cabaye althoff
cabaye attaque alors votre père officier
de l'armée française
oui votre mère turque musulmane avant de
percer un vrai militaire un tiers qui
l'employait à la maison pour vous les
mêmes mots qu'avec ce soda chez vous
mené à la cravache debout là dedans
c'est ce genre de phrase alors votre
maire en revanche l'a transmis son amour
de la musique
l écouter radio le caire le jeudi soir à
l'écouté oum kalsoum à spa assmann on
n'entendait pas beaucoup parce que
c'était une chanteuse re dit ensuite
votre père est muté en côte d'ivoire et
là vous vivez une vie de sauvageonne au
milieu des petits baoulé sous la
protection d'un dut nous nous sommes qui
s'appelait cococo qu il dormait sur le
seuil de votre chambre
coco était très long très très long j'ai
ligne et il s'est passé des choses
terribles à cette époque mon père était
un peu trash pas un homme spécial et il
a fait beaucoup souffrir une de mes
soeurs dont il a abusé en précisant et
12 ans nida et donc coco s'essayer dans
notre devant notre porte et sa
silhouette faisait un grand n comme ça
il dormait là alors en 1949 vous avez 5
ans la famille s'installe à marseille
dans un grand appartement sont votre
père qui à l'époque ch'ti en indochine
alors le problème c'est qu'au bout d'un
moment ils envoient plus d'argent et
vous êtes obligé de changer d'école
oui de tout vendre de sortir des
pensionnats on était toute mignonne à
billets
après c'était beaucoup plus dur mais
notre mère même si on n'avait pas
d'argent pour manger nous emmener au
cinéma alors c'est très rare à l'époque
les gens qui allaient au cinéma a
souvent ou ou qui acheter des disques et
des livres alors votre père disparaît il
reviendra quand vous aurez 10 ans
flanqué de deux vietnamienne oui avec
une nuée d'enfants
oui alors il repart il repart dans la
nature
et lorsqu il redonnera de ces nouvelles
cette fois c'est pour réclamer de
l'argent est là il faudra vendre
l'appartement
oui déjà dans cet appartement on vivait
sans électricité on se chauffer avec des
braseros nos camarades d'école trouvé
qu'on était très sauvage et voiliers par
des lampes à pétrole et ma soeur aînée
mamère cous et les la confection pour
que nous puissions survivre alors à
saison vous entrez aux beaux-arts de
marseille en cachette de votre mère est
à 19 ans vous mariez encore contre
l'avis de votre mère oui c'est difficile
parce que à cette époque là c'était
tellement sévère l'éducation qu'on ne
pouvait devenir adulte qu en se mariant
gelé regrettait d'ailleurs mais bon on
partait à paris avec votre mari vous
habiter chez son frère qui était pas
franchement sympathique vous avez un
boulot de dactylo vous cherchez la porte
de sortie
et là vous devenez mannequin oui mais à
l'époque je faisais 68 69 69
voilà avec le chignon les talons chinian
pompadour oui a déjà vous avez bien ça
allait à mes cheveux sinon mes cheveux
lâchés c c
une espèce de masse frisé comme ça et
maintenant une barbe à papa comme ça
alors là vous fréquentez le tout paris
et puis vous chantez à la fin des des
soirées c'est comme ça que vous faites
un petit peu connaître
malheureusement vous tomber enceinte
vous retourner à marseille
vous vous rendez compte que vous n'ayez
plus votre mari mais qu'en plus vous le
mépriser est là pour gagner votre vie
vous êtes disloqué dans les boîtes de
nuit
c'est en 1965 c'est l'époque c'est
vraiment il ya un espèce de souffle qui
arrive comme ça il ya des des groupes
avec des des chanteurs qui se qui se
déhanche se désarticule avec beaucoup
d'élégance et et de morgue et ça nous
soulage de cette espèce de ridder carcan
voilà de l'éducation et c'est comme ça
chez les premiers et rolling stones
aretha franklin semaine dave et vous
entrez enfin au conservatoire vous
apprenez à chanter là vous commencez à
vous produire en fait dans des
restaurants des petits gabarits oui vous
commencez à être un petit peu connu dans
la région
oui je fais des petits télé j'ai fait
une télé avec un un jeune homme qui
ressemblait l'enjeu loup qui s'appelait
bernard lavilliers et georges brassens à
ce qu'il nous avait pas de claude
françois aussi oui à qui vous avez
éviter un lynchage et c'est à dire que
le public de la provence c'est très
difficile c'est là on est arrivé après
une tauromachie à lunel et là il y avait
des bouteilles partout ça sentait la
piste de taureaux partout il y avait des
hordes de gitans qui ceux qui se
battaient avec une jouissance incroyable
et sauvage le soir donc quand le concert
a commencé c'était terrible on pouvait
plus sortir de des arènes on est nous
mêmes on sa santé le taureau partout
c'était terrible et c'est vrai que
l'aude était inquiet et jusqu'à présent
existe très méprisant avec moi parce que
quand il s'approchait des clodettes
il enlevait le bras faisait et poids
lourds tirer les cheveux il ya des
racines je passe à et lascaux l'enfiler
puis s'arrêter devant moi il faut parce
que moi j'avais mes cheveux comme ça
c'est celle surtout voilà j'étais
pallice du tout et je suis mis dans la
langue en dhr l'encadrement de la porte
qui l'avait insulté le public c'était
impossible
les gens jetés de tous sur la scène et
dans les arènes serre ont donc la foule
a fait comme une vague comme ça et s'est
précipité je me suis juste mis dans la
porte et j'ai reçu les premiers et je
pensais qu'il avait pas vus il avait le
soin où vous l'avez sauver du lynchage
en fait il vous attend au restaurant
avec ses lunettes noires vous arrivez en
général il dînait tout seul et là vous
parlez de lorient parce que je n'ai
évidemment sur le nil donc bien ses
coups ça vous rapprochez près alors là
vous êtes sélectionné par une émission
très importante à l'époque qui perçait
le dimanche après midi présenté par
raymond marcillac qui s'appelait le jeu
de la chance c'est de cette émission qui
était sorti thierry le luron imaxio
évidemment vous préféré donner l'argent
avant de partir de marseille pour
l'éducation de votre fille virginie et
vous ne faites pas une mission non je
supportais plus certaines musiques jeux
j'avais envie de faire la mienne j'avais
vu hoodstock était déjà passé dont crem
avait changé la vie aussi et c'est vrai
que notre mère nous avons éduqué
musicalement donc quelque part j'ai j'ai
pris le chemin petit peu difficile
d'aider cabaret de l'amant voilà vous
avez décidé de réussir autrement donc
vous ne faites pas le jeu de la chance
et vous commencez à faire les cabarets
au début c'est très compliqué vous êtes
vestiaire à l'échelle de jacob je vois
passer marie paule belle je vois passer
des jeunes
la manche dans les restos oui à
montmartre un jour vous êtes assise sur
les marches du sacré coeur d'être un peu
perdu arrive un gitan qui vous dit de
chasser les papillons noirs qui
volettent autour de vous et qui vous
offre une guitare et la veille j'avais
cassé ma guitare sur la tête de
quelqu'un pour me défendre parce que le
soir j'étais tout le temps à attaquer on
en voulait peut-être aussi à ma vertu
parce que j'étais une fille pas mal à
l'époque et en plus me prendre l'argent
que j'avais gagné à quoi donc je sais
plus quoi faire j'étais désespéré je
vois ce gitan avec des yeux injectés de
sang très sale qui faisait peur à tout
le monde qu'il fait une révérence qui
possède guitares crasseuses à mes pieds
mais qui m'a sauvé la vie
et c'est un signe du destin puisque le
lendemain vous êtes engagés dans god
spell à la porte saint-martin donc à
l'époque il y avait daniel auteuil et
dave qui faisait les auditions je les ai
vus faire les auditions avant il y avait
tous les hippies de deux heures une
foule complètement incroyable avec des
petites fumée du diable un peu partout
et là vous avez le rôle de marie
madeleine
oui en fait c'étaient des clones qui
jouaient toutes sortes de personnages
j'étais marie madeleine mais j'étais
aussi la femme adultère j'étais aussi
faim socrates a abandonné alors là votre
carrière est lancée donc vous commencez
à faire des albums des spectacles de
l'opéra des concerts mais josé vu en
concert au ou au bain au palace enfin la
voilà c'est toute la carrière disons sur
scène d'armande altaï ce mélange étrange
entre le classique et le contemporain et
laroque musique toujours ces deux mondes
et là vous commencez à faire du coaching
de voix alors des voix évidemment de
chanteurs beaucoup de grands chanteurs
sont passés entre vos mains
mais aussi des acteurs mais aussi des
hommes politiques et vous commencez à
vous faire une spécialité de ces cours
enfin oui dès que je vois quelqu'un j'ai
un regard de
comment on dit de quelqu'un qui s'occupe
des chevaux de maquignons je vois
quelqu'un je vois ses joues jeu-là ses
mâchoires
j'entends sa voix je dis qu'est ce que
ça donnerait si c'est dommage que là il
a ce petit truc et respire comme ça on
sent qu'il a peur on entend les petites
filles équipe qui pleurent les bureaux à
l'heure
les régions qui se cachent et ça devient
une des formations mais c'est
passionnant
ce sont ces techniques que vous
enseignez où 16 élèves de la star ac à
partir d'octobre 2001 vous qui étiez
dans la marge jusqu'au là vous devenez
célèbre c'est la notoriété des faits
surprenants way surprenant parce que je
ne pensais pas que la télé avait ce
pouvoir c'est arrivé très vite avec ça a
été dur lendemain je pouvais plus
marcher dans les rues des jours
lendemain mon mon répondeur était
remplie de gens qui chantent et je
t'aime ma boîte ma boîte aux lettres des
paquets qui tombait comme ça les mails
c'était par 400 500 par jour
je ne pouvais pas aller dans un
restaurant soit quelqu'un qui se lève
qui me fasse un concert un dans le métro
j'ai arrêté de prendre le métro parce
que les filles se levait me chanter une
chanson une autre de la poussée chanter
cette chanson populaire
quelle a été la réaction de votre
entourage à ce moment là alors c'est
curieux parce qu'il ya des gens comment
vous cautionnez ça c'est pas possible
vous qu'être marginale et en fait je dis
mais comment vous le savez vous avez
regardé et en fait ou non de regarder de
se poser comment avec le média je n'ai
pas arrêté d'en faire et à dire qu'il
est arrivé en 2003 je pouvais plus
mettre un pied devant l'autre
j'étais je ne pouvais plus parler
tellement tellement j'avais fait déjà
été filmée j'avais fait de de parlotte
de je sais plus ce que je disais je
tenais plus de ça ça a été un tourbillon
incroyable de gagner de l'argent
un peu pas tellement quand j'ai compris
ce qu'on donnait dans d'autres émissions
je me suis pas gros et son plan amoureux
ça vous a rapporté des aventures non
j'ai eu toutes sortes de propositions
bizarre messieurs à moustache à la fleur
un peureux d'un côté qui va envoyer du
fait bizarre mais non là je sais plus de
mon âge
oh je suis plus dans la course quel a
été le meilleur moment de cette époque
d'abord ce qui m'a le plus touché c'est
de voir tous ces gens de banlieue qui me
parlait pas vraiment avant que je me
disais on a compris qu'en travaillant on
pouvait se changer les pas de fatalité
pour vous exercice même si on fait wah
wah wah wah les voie moi il me le font
en tierce majeurs juste donc qu'ils ont
ils ont tous eu envie de ceux de
travailler sur eux
j'ai trouvé ça très bien et ce qui était
beau aussi c'est de voir gpal dans la
dernière se voir s'il chantait par
exemple répété plusieurs fois dans
s'aperçoit à quel à quel point les anglo
saxons travail par rapport à nous que
été le pied au moment de cette époque
lorsque
je voyais partir un élève camille qui
avait mis tous ses chevaux dans la
bataille et qui était mais complètement
cassés qui qui était comme s'il était
chassé du paradis
lorsqu'il partait en 2008 vous êtes
directrice de la star ac
malheureusement c'est la dernière saison
nous étions un peu déçus vous avez dit
la star ac a perdu de vue ce qui faisait
sa force la musique c'est à dire quand
vous voyez des choses qui n'étaient pas
du tout musical il préférait les
disputes en se lavant les dents comme ça
et puis
et puis c'est un peu le contraste c'est
tant pis je le dirham un contrat passé
avec tf1 c'est comme un contrat avec la
banque c'est-à-dire vous signez pour un
pourcentage pour des trucs tout ça et
puis hop il suffit que le gouvernement
dit quelque chose de votre contrat tiens
voilà vous êtes nostalgique de cette
époque dorée star ac
non je trouve que c'était bien qu'il y
ait eu ça beaucoup de chanteurs français
sont mis à chanter juste et en plein été
quand même une petite spécialité en
france c'était ça quel était le plus
grand talent pour vous qui est sortie de
la star ac
moi je pense à nolwenn bien sûr nolwenn
mais je la mets en équivalence c'est
comme si on me demandait de choisir
entre les enfants des fraises et du
chocolat
donc il ya aussi olivia qui est
magnifique qui est très créative que ce
petit jeune homme que j'avais trouvé -
après la première star ac
grégory lemarchal mais qui était pas
assez en forme à l'époque pour venir
encore vous avez de la rancune pour les
gens de cette époque pour tf1 pour le
non c'est dommage j'ai pas de la rancune
mais je voudrais qu'ils m'écoutent ou
qui met coutu qui l'écoutent qu'ils
écoutent davantage ce qui se passe ils
sont trop dans leur bulle il pense
encore comment en 2003 ouais alors que
on voit bien même endemol dans le monde
l'anxieux le côté en anxiogène de
certaines émissions s'efface au profit
de au contraire aller faire une semaine
à disney world ont même changé votre
maison va voilà et c'est s'est passé un
peu plus d'an au contraire dans une
espèce de joie parce que les gens sont
trop anxieux mais bon j'en voulais à
personne en fait non non non si c'était
à refaire armande qu'est-ce que vous ne
referiez pas pareil je me méfierais
davantage de certaines personnes mais
mais en fait je suis toujours je fais
toujours confiance parce qu'en fait
c'est vrai je me suis fait avoir on m'a
m'appuyer j'étais naïve mais je regrette
pas d'avoir la naïveté s'empêche de
vieillesse que le visage ne marque pas
continuez à rêver et 7 cette ouverture
m'a amené aussi des rencontres
merveilleuses alors je sais pas le jour
vous allez mourir
qu'est ce que vous voudriez qu'on écrive
sur votre tombe chaque fois que je
rencontre les gens ils font on écrire à
sa mère si j'étais très heureux de
rallumer un sursis merci à revendre
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux